this is a production of cornell
university
uh welcome back everybody this is
episode 15 of the cornell turf show this
spring 2022. uh we're going to have our
guest today is bill croiser
he is the president of the greenkeeper
app and he's also the superintendent of
jim air golf club
out there in nebraska you can follow
bill on twitter at pgr bill he's got a
lot of interesting video he does a lot
of extension and outreach and consultant
work on twitter as well so a good follow
for for all the things we'll talk about
today i'm sure
um but as always frank i'll let you get
it started today
uh with with uh as always our review on
the weather
are we still on the roller coaster are
we not you never
you were on the conference call this
morning uh it is it has been a
fascinating uh run uh this spring of
roller coaster weather but boy you know
i want to just say before we get started
golf course superintendents many of them
are exceptional photographers i just
have to say that you know i i do it so
much i don't give enough credit but i
you know just pull these off of twitter
very easily and it's so wonderful to see
pictures like this you know this was
reminds me of everything uh you know you
got working on a golf course for getting
up early and getting out there uh
cutting grass in the dew no problem
seeing your lines old guys like me have
a hard time seeing their lines would
have to do so i thought i'd put a couple
of really funny pictures up uh this is
the binkle dog here on the left up in
canada and it's first day look at the
size of those paws how big you think
that dog's gonna be carl and then on the
right you got jimmy buffett cruising
around a golf course in florida petting
the superintendent's dog i mean don't
you want to be a dog after seeing some
of these pictures all right carl so get
us going give us the bmp tip of the day
yes so one of the parts in in our
project here with the rit folks frank is
addressing nutrient management and one
of our pro tips it's not even one of the
things we uh we looked at in our survey
but just getting your growth rate right
and the idea of a consistent growth rate
leads to consistent turf and playability
and our guest bill kreuzer we'll we'll
talk about that today with him um but
we've you know in the past have we ever
measured growth um and what we started
doing at the cornell golf course a
couple years ago
was actually measuring the clippings
coming off of the of the golf green so
this was the data the first year we took
this data we did it for two different
greens and so you'll notice on this
chart
uh the y-axis is the amount of growth in
volume uh the clippings per unit area
mean you can see a little green range in
there i've got a green
square from 10 to 20 this is milliliters
per meter squared this is where the
greens performed well and so in that
first year we really just were kind of
getting some data okay what number are
the greens performing well at
that was the the range we liked uh the
problem as you can see is that growth
very rarely was in that range uh the the
black bars are precipitation large
precipitation events
very frequently we got a big shot of
rain and growth would surge
and then it would take us a while to
come back down and get back into our
green zone
uh so when we looked at this the first
year we said okay we have to address a
couple things uh one of it was the pgr
program we used in the next year the
superintendent dave hicks now retired he
used a different pgr program he would
change his pgr rates he did a little bit
more with the way he irrigated
and also doing some cultural practices
so this is the data in year two once he
got a little bit of that data under his
belt you could see that same green bar
right 10 to 20. we spent a lot more time
in that ideal range in the 2019 season
and this is a tool that he really liked
to use
trying to react to that sort of growth
and alter your management practices uh
responding to okay when i get a surge
how do i how do i suppress growth when
i'm a little low okay how do i need to
do maybe a little more nitrogen right so
responding to that getting your growth
rate more consistent gives you more
playing conditions and a great way to do
that is to measure the growth in the
first place
carl before i let you go on this point
how hard was this to do why two greens
talk a little bit about the way you went
about this because this is really
fundamental to not only our conversation
today but what we think is fundamental
to the way you should be uh managing
your playing services
yeah and i think when when people hear
data frank they think oh you know what
do i have to do to get that and this was
literally as simple as having a bucket
that's got uh volume measurements on it
after you mow a green you take the grass
and you're in your buckets on the mower
you dump it in there you write the
number down you get on your way it takes
less than 60 seconds really now the
thing that the reason why we did two
different greens at cornell where there
were two very different growing
conditions one's a very shady green a
lot of poa actually velvet bent grass in
that surface on the fifth hole this uh
blue line here
and then the seventh green is just right
out wide open
and the nice part is those greens are
kind of next to each other there was an
irrigation pump house that we put the
clipping volume bucket and the recording
sheet in so you can keep everything dry
you can have that as a centralized point
to take your measurements
um so finding an easy way to start kind
of dip your toe in the water i think is
a great way to do this
um and it
may be sounds okay how do i measure the
amount of grass it's literally as simple
as putting it in a bucket right i really
like i i call i really like how we
bracketed it's like we've got you know
one green that's the power green and
that's that multiple species in in the
fifth green
sort of
has times when it's well below other
times when it spikes up it adds sort of
the interest to
knowing how site-specific management
needs to be sometime and so i want to
remind everybody right carl we're not
going to be here next week we're going
to be in the field with tim han and his
crew
and the
gcsa ny walking around the links at
graystone
uh and we'll be talking bmps there and i
bet you uh the superstar rick slattery
might be in attendance as well i know
it's not that far from his house so you
may get a there may be a sighting
of a rick slattery sighting and that's
always great because once we get going
about the red sox and the yanks you
never know uh and there we are rick and
i the first twosome of the day uh the
turkeys of the day that we'll find out
there now carl to your point about the
roller coaster here's the april
up and down right the april
up and down up and then down and so you
go one more step into the first week of
may
right and you can see where we're
heading up right heading up a little bit
but we already heard this morning that
for us up north we're going to start to
see a increase but down in the downstate
area and to the south of the
metropolitan new york area
they're going into the cold weather
again it looks like
going down into much colder than normal
uh moving forward so last week we had a
slightly cooler than normal week inland
and a warmer than normal week i'm sorry
normal week along the coast but still
most a place is cooler than normal uh
not much growing degree day accumulation
to the north and when you think about it
as we heard this morning it's really
going to flip-flop um this coming week
it's going to be above normal warmth to
the inland west of the northeast region
and and cooler along the water uh so
you'll start to see a little bit more
degree day accumulation overall uh as we
start to warm but but there's still
going to be nighttime temperatures in
the new york metropolitan area into the
40s
over the weekend it does not look like a
great mother's day weekend
along the coast in the northeast but
i've been told inland that my barbecue
is safe
for my mom for not my mom but my wife
and her children our children right so
uh last week a little bit dry i think
we're starting to see this now a little
starting starting to get some deficits
everywhere but maybe up in uh new
hampshire and maine
much of the rest of the northeast
did not get much rainfall and is
starting to get into a little bit of a
deficit in fact um we had a little
conversation this morning on the
conference call about uh burn uh bans
and how low humidity gets to be a
problem in the spring around these sorts
of things
maybe a little conservative
in the way they predict it
but but overall we can see some drying
occurring now it does look like
some rainfall is going to be coming
along the coast in particular and there
will be places that will get you know as
much as one to two inches but in general
i think overall we're looking at a
deficit uh for much uh or right around
normal for much of the region with below
normal can below normal precip so that
could mean uh some restrictions on
growth so i'm going to get a pattern
going here bill
about growth as i bring you on first off
is where are the seed heads now right so
if you've done seed head suppression you
can obviously see the benefits of where
your thing where your plan worked and
where it didn't work because we're
really into heavy seeding um through
much of the metropolitan new york area
new jersey up the coast of new england
upstate still a little bit behind yet
but i would expect that to change
rapidly
this coming week now the other thing is
crabgrass
i did get some report this morning that
up against a building
up in springfield in the amherst area
there is a a couple of sprigs of
crabgrass coming but generally not very
much yet and obviously if you're using
pre-emergent materials just to remind
everybody seed head suppression growth
regulator pre-emergent herbicide growth
regulator
here's something that's not a growth
regulator but something you want to keep
track of ben mcgraw is saying a lot of
places where downstate especially where
uh peak adult emergence has occurred
where where the forsythias were half
green and half gold um
upstate we're still holding waiting for
peak adults downstate has been variable
but we're still a few weeks from those
of you looking for a larvicide
application now a little warning from
the usga that the roller coaster
temperatures are keeping these adults on
the edges of closer moan turf and that
could uh consolidate a lot of
populations and then intensify the
damage if you miss them
right so hopefully if they're all
crowded in one spot it allows an
application to be more effective uh but
also if you miss it it could lead to uh
damage now hopefully this is avoiding
multiple applications of the same
chemistries in the same spots that's
what we're trying to avoid now i've
started to add this little tidbit here
because we are routinely going out now
with insecticides either for annual
bluegrass weevil or for grubs uh
especially as you get downstate so you
want to be careful we do have a fair
amount of plants in flower right now you
certainly can see dandelions in various
stages of flowering so you'll want to
keep track of that flowering and hey
it's as simple as mowing it off uh
before you're going to make an
insecticide application so hopefully
you're mindful of that moving forward
the soils are still pretty cool uh we
did get some reports of 60 degrees down
in the southern new jersey area but
metropolitan new york is barely creeping
into the 50s and into the uh 40s still
in many areas upstate right so this is
also going to have a suppressive effect
uh on growth itself
now uh uh last week couple of weeks ago
we talked with mike fadonza about fairy
rings and how some of these soil
applications are being made now it still
looks like we're pretty early for summer
patch treatment looking at the 65 degree
trigger
for that so again keep in mind a lot of
these products have growth regulating
properties as well so you've got uh seed
head suppression you've got pre-emergent
herbicides you've got some of these
early season fungicides you've got
cooler temperatures you know you start
to look at all the things that we do
using growing degree days that might
have some regulate regulating effects
and bill
good to see you pal uh i will say i'm
sorry i got caught you in in between
taking air in these great videos that
you've been doing out at the jim edgar
golf course uh your one just the other
day
was brilliant and a perfect lead in
right for what we're talking about here
i love how you say you know i'm going to
be a little careful so i'm going to you
know remind everybody about this
wonderful blog article that you wrote in
your green keeper blog recently
about over regulation now you can for
those of you that are you know frequent
listeners to the program this isn't the
first time we've talked about this
especially with bill we've
even done it in in lawn systems
sometimes but bill you you you showed
your tool here in greenkeeper that i
want to take a minute and and talk
through with you now the podcast folks
are not going to have you know be privy
to necessarily seeing the images but
essentially i've got two graphs up here
that are built in your green keeper app
where
you're essentially going through what
you call a normal spring uh application
regime uh in your neck of the woods out
in nebraska which is you know i don't
think is that substantially different
from the kinds of things
we might be doing here and when you
start to look at the amount of
regulation that occurs in total when you
consider many of these products have
great
growth regulation properties you can see
in the you know in the above graph here
the amount of stacking as you described
occurs and you know you're approaching
80 percent growth regulation uh right
around the middle of may right as you
build this program out and so what
you've done on the lower graph is show
what happens when you adjust maybe the
products that you're using uh for some
of these purposes or uh the timing of
when you do it and so bill that's where
i want to start pal i'll i'll put it on
here here's i'm really looking at best
practices for spring
uh pgr use recognizing that many things
have plant growth regulating properties
let's you know i just classified it as
you know products uh programs the growth
overall and the transition so as i bring
in and look at you and stop staring at
the screen good to see you pal hope
all's well there um let's start with
you know your video and what you've
noticed out there because while we we've
noticed the exact same things i think uh
this way uh one of the things i thought
you said was telling and let's start
there
weather
could explain a lot of what people are
seeing independent of even a seed head
suppression right even a growth
regulator so let's start there what are
you seeing and it is or you know it has
been up and down that's something that
doug sold that and i talked about when
we were working together and we would
say
you know it's crazy you go out here one
day and you have all these different
research screens and they all look good
and then next day they all look bad and
so they're all under very different
management um and you would notice that
and so it's notice it again this this
week this this spring this spring has
been like kind of up and down uh pretty
bipolar in temperatures going from one
extreme to the next we're
in the 40s and 50s and then we're going
to be in the upper 80s next week and
it's just this is how it is in nebraska
we go from winter to summer uh and so i
think we have a lot of similarities
honestly to a lot of the great lakes the
mid uh atlantic and northeast because we
don't have a lot of warm heat in the
spring and so we do have to be careful
with what we're doing with our pgrs
because the growth rate started surging
last week when we were warm and wet and
now it's gotten really cold and cloudy
and i'm watching my clipping volumes or
falling off a cliff again and so until i
get some real stability in my program
until that bench grass is really
actively growing and continuing to grow
i'm going to be kind of careful with
what i'm doing because we can lead to
some problems if we if we just start
willy-nilly throwing down products and a
lot of the standard spring programs can
lead to a lot of
over-regulation if we're not careful
and so when you
see this right you know it starts with
how do you get folks off the
train a little bit of saying yeah here's
when we routinely put these things out
when they're not managing clippings
right i mean has it been your experience
that they're having these problems when
they're really not looking at their
growth as closely as they need to be
doing is is that the nature is that
where you started seeing the people hey
let's start doing this first like carl
said let's start getting this thing
because you're literally flying blind
yeah exactly it's one of the most
important things that i do at edgar with
our staff we collect clippings now from
three greens like carl says it takes one
minute per green to do
um and i do my shadiest green my
sunniest green and one in between and it
allows me to kind of capture what's
going on out there and honestly i don't
know how you fertilize and use pgrs
without having that number right we need
to get back to what these products do
and that's suppressed growth rate and so
let's use it as a tool and not just some
little like plant health product that we
just throw out at the same rate interval
all the time and so okay but here's the
point right the point is
even if they're good at that maybe
they've figured it out like you've
probably heard from guys like iphone
from i just go out every seven days i
can't be right i change the rate
sometimes they can't be bothered but
what about the hidden regulation of
these other products that's the thing
that i think your greenkeeper app has
done such a great job in highlighting
for people that look what you're doing
here and it's like i think in your video
or or in the article you say well i just
extended it a week
and i used this product instead of that
product and it's still got the same
efficacy so
that picture you showed before um of the
golf course in the foreground that
program was a standard pgr program for
that superintendent on top of a couple
of dmi fungicide applications and a
couple proxy applications
and so
and he knew it like at the end he's like
yeah i'm not getting any any growth you
know it's just like
you know he wasn't putting those two
things together until i saw that part of
the back of the green that wasn't
getting any proxy or it was just getting
dmi so there was dmi there but there was
no pgrs and there was no proxy and that
area was green and he's like oh yeah
they mow there they see that that growth
so
um a lot of these products can have
these growth regulating properties so
we've built models for both
cool season greens and bankrupt fairways
i'm actually working on doing this in
bermuda grass right now too for the
dmi's
regulation because it can be pretty high
i mean it can be as high as 30
40 suppression um which is similar to a
medium rate of say trim it so if you
start going out there with those apps um
that can be real sneaky even that proxy
is getting you 10-15 suppression
and if we're just applying it say on a
two-week interval and it's been really
cool like it has been there's a chance
that we still have some proxy regulation
there from the first app
um and then we go out a day later and
you're gonna water in an application for
your root diseases
and all of a sudden next thing you know
you have 80 suppression in a period of
time when the grass isn't really growing
yet because it's cold well let me let me
let me just throw in here um
we're lucky we got bent grass surfaces i
i think we're learning we could use a
few more bent grass surfaces after this
winter up here um how do you adjust some
of these things you're saying when
you've got a predominantly annual
bluegrass situation because in your in
your video
you're like my po is hurt my bed's okay
it's not growing but my po is hurting
can you talk a little bit about these
programs impacts on pola because guys
are putting summer patch down stuff
because they're trying to keep their
polo
yeah i think it's the bank crashes
really slowed down actually the po is is
still liking this weather it has been
cool and wet and so it's growing and so
my take home there is even though we get
in this habit of thinking i'm going to
use my class bpgrs right now i'm going
to be more aggressive on the poa it
actually really is hurting the bent
grass because the bent grass really is
slow to grow and so we're actually
favoring the poa because it's
differential levels of of suppression
you have a grass that's already growing
really slowly in the bank grass and
you're regulating it and then you have
the po that's making seed like you just
showed and seen seed heads are popping
obviously the proxy apps this year with
the weird weather we had weren't as
effective as they are in more standard
type years at least in nebraska i'm
seeing a lot of bridges so so with that
said i've heard this before right trim
it's sort of nasty on the bent grass in
particular right um would you recommend
a shift to cutlass that might not be as
uh rough on bank grass it might still
suppress polar or you don't like cutlass
suppression of polar no i'm fine with
that um the nice thing about your class
b's are your trim and your cutlass uh
they're both um pre-emergence and and
post-emergence type control the cutlass
doesn't seem to have as much gross
suppression as a trim it the trim it
really is the hammer it's the one that i
use the most in season to keep my growth
rate where it needs to be because i
adjust those rates all the time but this
time of year you know you can go with
some softer products so the cutlass
materials would be a good option there
and it seems like from the herbicide
data that um with cutlass we see this
reduction in pull-up maybe not the level
of trim it um but still the second best
of the pgrs but again we're not we're
getting that as a side effect of not
much growth suppression so that would be
an option or you know going with the the
new would be kind of that third and then
your your primo would be kind of the
weakest of all the pgrs especially on
hurting that poa so you know right now i
had some primo out there um and i'm just
kind of waiting for things to happen i'm
sure i'm gonna see another growth surge
okay that's my question before you go
there you guys are expecting what we're
expecting i think carl we heard is going
to be in the 80s uh on wednesday right
so how do you manage this where it's
been damp damp damped and whoop it's
going to go like this is there something
you
would do in advance of that or would you
wait till that surge starts to happen
how is all this regulation and damping
we're seeing now going to manifest
itself
third that's when
good question and that's a p uh a part
of the the puzzle that we're working
hard to uh
to get ahead of and that's what like
doug sold that's working with with some
of his clipping prediction models right
uh and something that we're building in
the green keeper right now so where
people are adding their clipping volume
and green keeper it starts to learn how
their grass is going to grow from this
year's data so that next year it will
see always a big warm-up coming or a big
rain event because the carl's data you
showed when we had the big rain events
we especially after a dry period we see
this growth flush so that prediction
even if it's a week or two weeks in
advance it's going to be helpful because
we'll see okay growth rate's going to
grow up so before i have that model
which we'll get maybe next year with
this year's data
i was looking at it from my past
experience saying okay it's been very
wet it's going to get really warm i'm
going to get a big growth surge so i'm
going to go out on monday with pgrs
expecting that surge
and so i'm watching my green keeper
display there and you know
we've been talking about uh growing
agreed intervals for so long oh my god
um but i'm kind of moving away from
intervals now with this model you can
just see the suppression and if you need
more you can still go out on a monday
but now you're going to see how is it
going to stack you know that's a term
that you coined years ago when we had
these talks about pgr stacking and you
know i've continued to use that that
term and so it's okay for me to stack on
monday because i know i'm going to get
this growth surge out of it and i want
more suppression um
and so you know some of the things we
talked you showed before
for in the interim when i had this cool
weather you know i did a proxy by itself
then i did proxy with a new at a low
rate
stretched it out on my growing degree
day intervals so maybe it wasn't two
weeks but it was like three and a half
weeks because of the cool weather and
then i decided to use some of the newer
dmi products like a density core versus
maybe a banner or attorney that have a
lot more suppression with them and so
i'm constantly you know looking at that
and figuring out how much suppression do
i need and that viewing green keeper
really allows you to see how all those
things are stacking up and then how
they're going to go
function in the future based on the
forecast data and then the long term
based on the normals data right because
it's hard it's hard for these operations
sometimes to be nimble carl i know
you're chomping at the bit you got a
question for bill
well i think you transitioned right into
it bill is the forecasting element i
think is is where we're going with this
and it's why it's very cool to hear you
talk about forecasting clipping volumes
because
you know like the data i showed with
with dave hicks from the cornell golf
course it was very reactive right it was
okay today we got a little more
the next day okay now we're at like 20
and okay now
and then i got to wait five days until
my monday right and this forecasting
element i think gets that next step
where now you can plan a little bit in
advance instead of being a little bit
more reactive like like we have been
when you're just taking the data
so my question is those models uh you
know so you're you're talking about
learning based on on field data right
and and that is the maybe the best way
to
it'll be yeah so for example like from
me collecting clippings for 15 18 years
now we know that growth rates generally
really slow in june and then they pick
back up in summer when we have
mineralization and so intuitively we
start making those observations and we
built that mental model your mental
model then has increased with okay we
have a big rainfall
that's forecasted i'm going to get ahead
of it with pgrs right so what we're
doing with greenkeeper and with doug's
just finished his phd student um through
is let's let the computers figure out
all those crazy different okay
temperatures like this and it's this
time of year is this brass species i let
it kind of learn so all you have to do
is just put in your clipping volumes and
let greenkeeper track what pgrs did you
use what fertilizers what was the
weather like what time of year was it
and they will start to then learn and
then the more data you put in the better
the model gets over and over so it's
just moving to the next level and then
and at the same time bill right this is
what carl i likes you know this is what
he figured out from hanging out with
dave
right you know you got to spend a fair
amount of time with dave to get that
range nailed down with him i love him
but that's my brother but you know
getting that range and performance is
part of it right so you can put
performance data into greenkeeper as
well are you able to tie in growth
regulation
clipping volume and ball roll yeah we're
actually putting ball roll model i hired
my old phd student and just finished a
couple weeks ago and that's one of the
things we're going to work on so that
say you're a superintendent and you have
a tournament in a week and you need your
greens to be rolling 12.
greenkeeper would
say okay well you're gonna need to mow
uh every day and roll
uh 12 times in the next two weeks to get
to that level and your quality then is
going to do this yeah right it's just
it's it's things that we're already
doing in our head like our greens need
to be faster which are double rolling
but now it's just saying well how many
times i could double roll or does it
make sense to mow in the evening or not
and so that's what we're trying to uh to
do with this so if you can just the more
data you can feed into
the site uh the better it's gonna be at
predicting these types of things bill it
always goes too fast pal it's great to
see you yep uh carl uh final comments
from the from the live audience or you
want to get us out of here
i'll get one more question and bill and
and i think for people listening who
haven't ever collected clipping volume
and maybe they've heard about and they
go hey you know they they got their own
mental model um what's what's your pitch
to saying hey here's why you should do
this data and i know we're talking about
these models and they're going to
predict what ball roll is and yeah
people in their heads are like wow i
know how to do that what's your pitch to
those so right now if you track first of
all it prevents people from being too
reactive to seeing that the growth rate
was really high in one particular day
and so if you're looking at it it's a
written down data series you can
actually see are you trending up or down
right so that's an important thing and
then the other part is if you keep track
of your clipping volume for the whole
year we can make really nice assessments
of how much nutrient was mowed most mode
off right and so by balancing those two
things you're actually getting some
better perspective over an entire year
in terms of where your growth is going
what they may be next week or two weeks
but then also how much fertilizer did
you mow off and did you at least put
somewhere near that back down or not and
and so i think that gives another level
of visibility that you just don't have
without tracking these data
i think it would be virtually impossible
bill to find someone who knows more
about plant croats regulators than you
do it's always great to see you i just
love this i love how it's coming to
these hidden uh growth regulators
because that's where i've consistently
seen guys get in trouble especially in
the spring with the cavalcade of
products that we get pushed to use for
the variety of problems we think we
might face so good to see you again bill
thanks a lot for joining us carl we got
to get out of here it's 32 minutes
thanks thanks to bill uh thanks for
jumping on today tomorrow our episode
will feature john sorakan of tennessee
we'll be chatting sports turf
just one more reminder we're not on uh
next week's uh episode we're we're gonna
be in the field up in rochester so if
you're around us uh feel free to sign up
for that gcs ny event but no golf
episode next week uh we'll see you guys
tomorrow
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu